[Music]
say yes that's me Rachel Andrew this is
my second time at CSS comps EU I've done
a few CSS comps around around the world
now really great to be here Berlin is
very much my favorite city so I take any
chance to come here so I'm going to talk
it's a non technical talk which is
unusual for me my sort of comfort zone
is to have 150 slides of code so I've
had to write a non-technical talk I'm
going to talk about where CFS comes from
and if we wanted to be literal about
this it comes from 1996 because that's
when the CSS 1 specification was
published and in the same year
we got ie 3 and that was the first
browser which had some CSS support and
very neatly my career as a web developer
started in 1996 I am one of those people
who had to install her web browsers from
CDs that were sent by the ISP so if
anybody else could remember doing that
anyone else anyone I was old was a few
of you we can all get together remember
the good old days later so I've been
working on the web for a long time and
so my history as a web developer sort of
has gone along with CSS I started to
build websites without CSS because it
wasn't a reality that I had version 2
browsers
there was no option other than font tags
and nested tables that was just how
things were done and the really amazing
thing about CSS other that we talked
about this enough is the fact that all
of those early things we built and as we
started to use CSS as we started to use
CSS for layout all that stuff really
still works
CSS remains backwards compatible and
that's really important and therein lies
a lot of the problems that we actually
have with CSS in terms of creating CSS
and using CSS is this you know we can't
go around breaking the web
so I'm not really going to talk about
the history of CSS today that's just
pretty well-documented what I really
want to talk about is where does CSS
come from today where does new CSS come
from what's the process how do we go
from an idea to something that ends up
in a browser because I hear all kinds of
strange theories and kind of like weird
conspiracy theories about where CSS
comes from and I think some of that
actually does have its roots back in in
the olden days back in the days when I
became a member of the web standards
project because browser vendors were
competing at one point on platform
features so they were bringing out new
CSS features and saying well we've got
this I we've got this and Netscape
hasn't got it and ultimately we were
building if you wanted to do cool new
stuff you'd build two websites you'd
build one for Internet Explorer one for
Netscape you detect which browser the
user hadn't you'd send them to the right
website and this was terrible and people
didn't want to do that would put best
viewed with buttons on their web pages
that's horrible and people kind of
expect that browser vendors are locked
in some battle about CSS and actually
what really happens looks a bit like
this this certificate the CSS working
group meeting in Tokyo a couple of weeks
ago we were all locked in that room no
one was allowed to go for coffee and so
we decided what happens to line-height
when you've got two founds of different
character sets next to each other
now just in that photo there are people
from Microsoft Google Mozilla and
several other companies and they're all
working together on a particular CSS
issue and you can have a look at the
current members of the CSS working group
it's a whole bunch of people making CSS
representing lots of different browser
vendors and other people there's lots of
people there who work who work on things
like ebooks epub and outputting CSS to
print so you can have a look at their
affiliations the people who are there so
any CSS specification passes through
this group we get the opportunity to
debate parts of the spec and vote on
changing or adding features and that we
stops one vendor a one-party dragging a
specification away from what would
benefit the web as a whole and the specs
have to start somewhere so they come
from all sorts of places they often do
come from a particular browser vendor in
order to solve problems that that vendor
thinks are important they may be kind of
problems they see in their business but
it's not just browser vendors the CSS
shapes spec started life with Adobe and
others come directly from the working
group because they're going to solve
some problem that we see or we know we
need a way to do a certain type of thing
to enable something else and so those
specs might come directly from the
working group so I wanted to take a look
at this process and I thought I'd do
that via CSS grids because if you know
me you'll know that I'm a bit of a grid
superfan and I've been working with the
spec for quite a long time and so I kind
of know the history of this
specification so let's talk about CSS
specs via grid and what happened to that
and how it became something that we
could use in browsers so how did that
start out quite a long time ago it's
2011 we got a first public working draft
now if you go and have a look at that
document you'll find that a lot of the
concepts there seem pretty familiar if
you've used modern grid layout so north
a lot of the features that you use a
kind of outlined in that spec there
might have different names or look a bit
different and things are a little bit
vague around the edges but it's kind of
all there so it's six years before it
made into our browsers we have this
first draft and in fact it goes back a
long way the ideas in grid go back to
around 2005 this is the CSS advanced
layout module it looks very like some of
the stuff that's in the grid spec the
grid template areas ASCII art syntax
pretty much describes in this spec and
that's often the case of working group
things you get these notes these
collections of ideas that may well
become something that we have in CSS but
might just kind of float around just
like when you're developing any products
you kind of have these ideas and you
think oh yeah that would be
cool maybe we should think about
implementing that and it gets kind of
put on the back burner that happens in
CSS as well so a working draft now a
working draft is essentially a snapshot
of the state of the spec at a particular
date and it means we can reference it it
means I can write about it and say oh
you know on this date this working draft
this is the names of the properties it's
useful to have a reference of the state
of respect
now publication of a working draft
doesn't mean a lot in terms of
implementation it doesn't mean the specs
mature it might not be finished it might
have great big holes in it it's just the
snapshot of where the work was on that
day if you want to see where the work
actually is today you want to look for
the editors drafts and they're always
linked from the working draft now that's
what the spec editors are actually
working on right now so that would be
the most up-to-date thing but could be
completely different to the working
draft and any experimental
implementations it's you know where all
the bug fixes are going and if you take
a look at that first public working
draft you'll see the editors listed and
those spec editors were from Microsoft
so the initial grid spec came from
Microsoft you have them plank for the
fact we have grid at all in addition to
drafting this first version of the spec
they created an experiment
implementation in ie10
so grid is in ie10 and up its ms prefix
because that's how experiments were
released in those days so in general as
specs are developed if they've come from
a browser event there's going to be some
experimental implementation that they've
done back in the day it was a vendor
prefixes now they tend to be behind
flags and these give you the chance to
play around with new CSS which is really
important and I'll come back to that in
a bit so the experimental invitations
let the vendors the browser vendor and
also the working group know whether this
is something that people are interested
in and to start to look at the problems
that might be in that spec and it was
where my journey with gridlayout began
with this experimental ie implementation
I tend implemented quite a lot of the
features in the spec not everything but
it was enough to make me realize that
this was something that we wanted and
what I also knew through having followed
CFS for such a long time was that new
stuff often needs someone to promote it
it needs superfans it needs someone to
go out there and talk to other web
developers and say look at this cool
thing because it through that that
interest is gauged and that we can have
actually get this stuff into all of our
browsers so I thought well I'm going to
start talking about this I want to start
telling people about this spec and use
what I knew about teaching CSS so I've
been teaching basic CSS and it's about
2001 sort of take what I knew about that
and apply it to this thing that was
experimental and start talking about it
and while I was doing this the spec
moved on and for quite a while I was
talking I was standing on stage talking
about something which didn't have a
browser implementation because the spec
was different to what was in i8n but we
didn't have any news any new
implementations thankfully that didn't
last too long because it was kind of
hard making up how this stuff might work
and we started to get an implementation
in blink and WebKit which is done by a
company called agalya and actually
sponsored by Bloomberg and here's a
little bit of CSS history because the
first time I met the people from a Galia
doing that implementation and also some
from Bloomberg was here at CSS comps in
2014 where I was talking about CSS grid
layout and I was actually pretty nervous
once I realized they were all here
because I was going to be talking about
the work that they were doing and they
were going to be in the room so that was
very scary but it was very night it was
great to meet them and we we sort of
chat back and saw us on Twitter now and
things and I've been in touch than ever
since I think it's also interesting that
Bloomberg sponsored the development of
CSS grid in blink and WebKit so they
wanted the feature they wanted it for
the embedded chromium that's inside
their terminal product so they wanted
that platform feature and by sponsoring
it as an open web feature we all get it
and they get what they need for their
business
that's very interesting and Bloomberg
about responded quite a lot of features
and CSS and JavaScript to be implemented
into browsers so by this point we had
some implementations and we were
starting to work with those and I was
presenting about grid and talking to web
developers that you know people like at
CSS conf and something came up over and
over again and it was this there was no
way to create a gap between tracks in
the grid and people immediately looked
at grid and said well it's a bit like
mode two column layout why don't we have
something like column gap in grid now in
the IE implementation it was kind of a
bit annoying but it didn't really matter
too much he didn't have gutters what you
could do is define little skinny tracks
in your grid and use those as gutters
because you had to place everything
explicitly on the grid but the new
specification had this idea of also
placement so you could define a grid and
then throw a bunch of content asset and
grid will just Auto place it's a bit
like with Flex box where things you know
place one after the other with no
gutters you couldn't use auto placement
because grid would try and place items
into those skinny tracks so that was an
idea so I was talking about this on
stage and saying you know this isn't
great web developers are talking about
this and saying we need to have some
kind of gap between our tracks which led
me to discussing the issue with their
people from the working group and one of
the spec offers she wrote the feature
into the spec where it was implemented
and became part of the level 1 spec
which means that a bit of code like this
with those 10 pixel gutter tracks could
be simplified and would end up looking
like this and the thing about this is I
mean that was just one thing that kind
of went into the spec that I you know
remember and I was kind of part of but
the important thing about that is that
that was feedback from the web community
making its way into a CSS specification
because we were playing with an
experimental spec we were able to make
changes to that spec and
time I wasn't a working boot member I've
only been a working group member and for
for about a year so what are the working
group member and I was just talking to
other web developers but we were able to
make a change the level one spec we can
do this with any new bit to the platform
that were interested in so we've got a
spec that's kind of in this state and
it's changing and it's becoming
different as it's moving along and
browsers are implementing at the same
time so we've kind of got a spec and
we've got browser development and things
are changing in the spec and the
browsers are having to make changes
because of that and that's kind of how a
lot of things happen in this kind of
circular way where we get an
implementation and we get the specs
developing alongside each other it's
certainly not a case that the working
group sort of hide in a room and develop
a specification throw it at browser
vendors and say well they go you know
good luck with that
this thing happens in a circular way and
this iterative development has happened
for a very long time with specifications
but as many people know this is bit
nerves in the past if you try to use
early flexbox for example in a
production site it was vendor prefixed
you could use it in a production site
and you might have a site working and
then a new browser came out with a
different implementation of flexbox at
one point there were kind of three
different implementations of flexbox out
there in the wild now grid has changed
even more than the flexbox spec did but
it did so behind a feature flag in
browsers which meant that no one could
use it for production code so we didn't
have this issue if it kind of been out
there and biting people as the spec
changed it so that's really the
difference between developing with
vendor prefixes which has really gone
away and developing with feature flags
it's enabled respect to change and to
have this issue ative process of browser
development and spec development without
that then sort of getting into our sites
and causing us problems
so it took till 2016 for the SPECT for
the working group to essentially say we
think this is probably done that's quite
a long time it's a very very big spec
when the working group thinks something
is pretty much done how its voted to
become a candidate recommendation and
what that means is the spec has moved on
from being a working draft and the way
think of things this is time it needs to
have implementation experience we think
this spec can be implemented we think
it's useful we think it does the things
it's set out to do you know do we have
implementation experience
so how vendors implemented everything
and the next step will be a proposed
recommendation so this is like saying
well this is what we think is going to
be the spec and we need to have two
independent interoperable implementation
of all of the features so that means
that we need to have two browsers really
that have implemented the features and
not only do you need to have two
browsers the work needs to have been
done by two different people or groups
of people so the work done by a Galia
say in web WebKit and blink that
wouldn't really count as two
implementations they're different
browsers actually pretty much the same
code because I think Graham was broken
on that before the the projects Forks
but it's the same company doing that
work but we've also got the work in
Firefox
so because you've got the work in
Firefox done by a different team we've
got two implementations and so hopefully
grid will be able to progress you know
once all the little pubs have been
worked out and all of the features are
implemented gradually as progress on and
the reason we have this requirements
that make sure that we don't have things
that are you know WC recommendations
with only implemented in one browser or
perhaps could only be implemented in one
browser because of the way that browser
works something you might see in the
spec if you in fact you look at the
current working draft you'll see that
something called sub-grid is marked as
at-risk in the spec and what this means
actually in the current editors draft
subgrid has been removed it's been
pushed to level 2 and this at-risk flag
what it means really is this is a
feature that we think
might not be able to be implemented by
two implementations it might not be in a
state that we can actually get that and
move the speck on in a timely manner so
we flag it is at risk that doesn't mean
that the thing will never be implemented
and in fact sub-grid was discussed at
the last working group meeting we had a
breakout session on it it's still very
much on the cards but it's been moved
into level 2 of the spec rather than
dropped so it essentially moved into a
different release of that bit of CFS I
just like you might decide that a
certain feature of your product is going
to get bumped into another release so
that you can ship the stuff you've been
working on your CSS works pretty much in
the same way so March 2017 we got grid
in all of these browsers and edge of
also announced that they're going to be
updating too so it took a very long time
it took almost six years to get grid
into browsers so wide earth to CSS take
so long it's partly because there's a
lot of stakeholders it needs to be
implemented in browsers in a way that's
not going to cause problems or
performance problems accessibility
issues and behind every browser is a
business and they're going to have
different priorities they need to be
able to schedule a team to work on
something to get that implementation in
the browser so we got grid because
Microsoft thought it was interesting to
start with and then Bloomberg we're
willing to fund it into other browsers
there's also us authors the people who
write CSS CSS has to make as much sense
as possible to web developers because if
something is just too complicated or
crazy-looking what people might not
implement it they might not use it and
then there's no point having that CSS
tool introducing this talk I mentioned
how amazing it was that CSS doesn't
break things it's backwards compatible
this is really really important and it
will come as no surprise to people in
this room that some of CSS is a bit
suboptimal
so behold the list of things that we're
going to fix in CSS just as soon as
someone has invented a time
machine so if it seems that some CSS is
really really weird at doing a bit of
digging might just turn up why it's so
weird which at least will confirm that
the CSS working group aren't just trying
to make your life hard but also if I
understanding why things seem really
weird it can help you understand and
remember that you know it may be because
it was added a long time ago we didn't
know the web was going to be like this
and it may be because they're new but
they have to cope with something added a
long time ago when we didn't know the
web was going to be like this and
sometimes they're weird because they're
dealing with stuff that you don't run
into there's some stuff that's weird
because it has to cope with languages
that were in right-to-left on top to
bottom as well as left-to-right there's
lots and lots of stuff in CSS which is
dealing with that kind of issue so
trying to figure out why things seem odd
can just help you remember them but what
is really important is that you can help
to influence the direction of CSS far
more than you imagine that you can and
you can do this in a whole bunch of ways
that I'm going to cover it now because I
really as someone who is just a web
developer you know running a tiny
company I'm not from a big browser
vendor and I'm on the working group and
the thing that I like to do is take
people's feedback to the working group
take other web developers feedback and
bring it to the working group so here's
way everyone can be doing that one of
the simplest ways to get involved is to
go to browsers and ask for features to
be implemented a lot of browsers have
got official ways of doing this go and
use it both the stuff post stuff up tell
browsers that you want stuff but even
more important is to start using things
especially if that stuff only exists in
one browser at the moment browser
vendors are tracking usage of features
to see what the demand is for the
feature so here you can see the usage of
flex this is on Chrome status they're
tracking see how often this stuff is
used Microsoft has got a similar data
gathering effort if you use a feature in
production even if it's just on your
personal site and even if you have to do
a fallback for other browsers that
is noted and it's like oh well people
are wanting this because they're using
it for things that are tucked away
behind browser flag using them in
production is impossible but another way
to show interest is if you write or talk
about this stuff write posts on your
blogs you talk about the thing do
presentations at meetups or whatever
this photo is a screenshot from event
part in Seattle which is when edge
announced they were going to update
their grid implementation they responded
on stage to an email I sent them in 2014
chasing them up about updating that ie
10 implementation browser vendors are
listening they want to know what we want
make sure that they get that message and
it's not just about speaking to browser
vendors you can actually take part in
developing CSS itself here you don't
need to be a special person you don't
need to be an advice expert the CSS
working group to get involved as we need
designers and developers to take a look
at new stuff to make suggestions about
things that we haven't solved yet in CSS
everything that happens at the CSS
working group happens in the open so you
can follow along with what's happening
and you can you know make your own
comments these specifications and issues
raised against them are held in github
in the Citiz working group drafts
repositories you can go and you can have
a look at that and you can see what
issues have already been raised you can
comment on them you can raise some of
your own there the series written people
on Twitter and things are posted there
that we're working on and also sometimes
direct questions are posted there quite
often about naming what should we call
this property because we don't know and
we're asking for feedback you can also
see all of the current work of the CSS
working group so you can see if there's
something that you think you'd like to
comment on feature request to CSS you
can request those in very much the same
way you'd ask for any feature of a
product and the best way to do that is
to come up with us or the use case as
opposed to proposing syntax actually the
syntax or sense is very very hard to
kind of work out because it has to cope
with all
old stuff and legacy stuff and quite
often we go round and round on names
quite a few times before it's decided
what it's going to be but the use case
is the important thing now what problem
are you trying to solve with this CSS
and our authors already working around
this in some way a lot of the time
people are doing things in JavaScript
that would make a lot of sense to be
able to do in CSS what if we've got that
JavaScript implementation then that's a
really good test case for well hey know
how do we actually do this in native CSS
so that's really useful and if using you
know using javascript to do things isn't
a bad thing and but are there problems
because of that use of JavaScript you
know is it creating a performance issue
that perhaps we could solve that it was
part of CSS so that sort of stuff if you
can bring that into an issue on github
if people are going to look at that and
then they talk about it you know we
bring up these things in working group
meetings and talk about them and try and
see if there is a way that they could be
solved so as an example you can go and
have a look at one of the things that
happens people start to look at CSS grid
and they say oh you know can I just
style the backgrounds of grid areas can
i style column tracks can i add borders
to them and the answer the moment is no
you have to put an element in there to
style them and it's kind of creating
containers for elements so we need some
kind of grid cell pseudo element in
order that you can style the backgrounds
and borders absolutely a lot of people
have asked for so it's something that
has been put in as an issue and quite a
lot of people have commented on that
thread this thing you're interested in
you can always go and read and see if
you've got anything else to share so
this is how new CSS is happening if
people are asking for things and we're
talking about them and trying to work
out the best way of doing that so that
would probably that'd be a level two
feature now you can see it's got a CSS
grid to a flight tag on it so that we
can sort of keep track on it as we start
to look at the level to a CSS grid
layout now it's not just about new
features there are bugs in
specifications and you know the CSS
effects so it can be very long and
complex and they can end up with bugs
then if you spot something that's an
issue come and raise it if it turns out
it's not an issue it might just be that
we need to clarify that bit of respect
there because someone thinks that what's
said in the spec is actually wrong so
that's actually a bug as well to what
the specs to be clear so common log
issues against respects and web browsers
they'll be very happy to hear about your
interrupts issues too you can go and you
can log bugs and any browser if you find
saying that it's not working in a
browser go and tell them about it
because quite often it's when people get
their hands on new CSS they start using
it with some other CSS they start using
it with some JavaScript or in
conjunction with a framework and that
shows that bugs that no one spotted
before if you find them go and log them
that helps everybody and you learn this
great thing when you log bugs you learn
how to make reduce test cases which I
believe is a web development superpower
and not enough people are good enough at
doing this it makes your life a lot
easier if you learn how to make a reduce
test case not just for logging bugs but
also fixing problems in your own work
getting good at stripping down problems
the simplest case really makes
everything that you do an awful lot
easier and it will help other people to
reproduce your bug and to fix it quickly
the thing is what I found is that
contributing to CSS has been an amazing
way to learn about CSS what I've learned
in the last few years following the grid
spec and ultimately becoming part of the
CSS working group has been absolutely
amazing and I've been doing this for
twenty years and I feel like I have
learned so much yeah I contribute to CSS
I spend a lot of time doing free work
essentially for the web platform but I
think we're pretty much even because it
gives me so much back in terms of what
I've learned as I've done that you know
what I've learned by raising an issue
and then having all of the implications
of that explained to me you know I
couldn't have got that anywhere else so
I've learned so much by contribution to
CSS it's been very very much worth it
and so really to answer that question
aware does CSS come from where does
modern CSS come from there's absolutely
no reason why the next amazing feature
can't come from any one of the people
sat in this room today in very real ways
CSS comes from people like you and me so
be part of it because it is great fun
thank you very much for listening you'll
find lots of resources at that link
there and you can find me all over the
web and I love talking about this stuff
so please do come have a chat to me
thank you all right good